[Music]
I think the original the problems we
have in life is that we cannot sit alone
in a room doing nothing and I didn't
come up with this theory this was
blessed Pascal who wrote about it in the
1640s here in the States
people in are rich they watch the
telephone for hours every day which
means in the States you probably live
around 30,000 days in your life which
means that you sit watching it telephone
120,000 dollars let's say only 80
percent of it is wasted which leaves you
with 96 thousand dollars you're actually
doing mostly bullshit all the time then
again of it life will feel really short
because in life you need variety you
need novelty no novelty but when you
keep on doing the same thing throughout
the whole day throughout your whole life
the conclusion of your life will be that
has been really short and very boring
now to me wonder is the very engine of
life and I walked really long distances
took me actually almost 40 years before
I learned that pleasure walking short
distances but I walked instance to the
North Pole with my friend Berger auslan
all the way to the top of Earth and then
I also walked Mount Everest base camp
and eventually climb all the way to the
top of the mountain and thirdly I walked
all the way to the South Pole in total
solitude as the first in history I
didn't have any radio contact I didn't
talk to anyone on a trek I was
absolutely letter to myself and for the
first couple of hours before day or two
you have all this noise in your head
although it's absolutely quiet around
you you're thinking and then you think
you think about the past you think about
the future
and all this you know it's like noise
but then time pass by you slowly start
to think so much you start much more too
experience to feel being present in the
moment and that's when it's really great
to be on an expedition that somehow the
future does matter the pastor's mother
all that matters is to be present in
your own life I've traveled to more than
100 countries in the world and met many
people in its place have been and my
impression is that most people and
estimate their own possibilities in life
obviously some people are overestimating
their possibilities but in general
people are under estimating their own
possibilities and for instance when
people tell me I don't have time for
silence
I'm too busy I'm too important it's not
for me
I don't believe it I think they all have
time for some silence and but the reason
we try to avoid silence is because
silence can be a bit frightening and it
can be a bit uncomfortable because
silence is about getting to know
ourselves while noise not only sounds
but all kinds of distractions and
expectations and be being in timbre
things from your phone it's about
running away from yourself it's not
about forgetting yourself is about
living through other people it's about
living through apps and consequently not
fully but partly it is about wasting
your life
it's about missing out on this huge
opportunity to live richer life the
first told story I know about about
walking is the story when Adam and Eve
actually walked off to Paradise and I
really love that story because the left
paradise and became history's first true
explorers they want to eat from the tree
of knowledge as soon as I did they just
walked out and that's what you know we
have been doing ever since and that's
what makes life beautiful humans have
always explored the world in a physical
sense you have been walking we have been
touching they've been smelling you have
been
seeing I mean free singing I've been
sweating we have been tired we have been
relieved throughout life while we have
been working while today for the first
time in history mine is almost all about
sitting on our arses working down into a
screen or just in front of us this whole
idea that you can actually experience
the world get to know people respect
human humanity try to understand what's
going on on the earth by looking into a
screen it's a huge mistake so in that
sense we should learn from Adam and Eve
we need to just walk off into the world
and try to understand and see and feel
what's going on
[Music]